Wildlife officials in Alaska are not
sure what is causing an increase in bear
attacks they include two deadly
encounters in just two days earlier this
month now there have reportedly only
been six deaths from bear attacks in the
state over the last 130 years
Jeff Flores in Anchorage near the scene
of one of the latest deadly attacks Jeff
good morning Gail good morning - there
hadn't been a fatal bear maulings in
Chugach State Park here since 1995 but
now one of the trails was closed down
temporarily and many people are steering
clear just as the busy summer tourist
season arrives a big race scheduled for
Alaska in July has been canceled they
are one of the biggest draws in the
nation's biggest states but now bear
country is getting unsettling attention
On June 18th 16 year-old Jack Cooper was
chased by a black bear after running a
race in Anchorage Cooper used his phone
to tell his family what was happening
but by the time he was found it was too
late just a day later southeast of
Fairbanks a biological technician and
newlywed named Erin Johnson was also
mauled and killed by a predatory black
bear in this past weekend two separate
brown bear attacks both victims survived
this is a lot of people very worried
should they be well it's good to be
careful in bear country and they can
move faster than a person oh yeah
Rick Senate is a wildlife biologist who
worked for 28 years at Alaska's
Department of Fish and Game
we met emit bird rich where Jack Cooper
was killed it hasn't happened in Alaska
to have two black bear attacks two days
apart there's only been six predatory
black bear attacks in Alaska that that I
know of I think in history so all of a
sudden to have to and course of two days
is it's a lightning strike most bear
attacks come from brown bears and they
are typically defensive moms protecting
Cubs black bears stalking victims is
almost unheard of Sara Leonard runs the
Alaska Travel Industry Association she
is also a mom you have a 13 year old son
you're sending him on a hiking and
camping trip and you thought thought
about it for a second I did think about
I think it's natural when something
this tragic occurs but knowing that it
is so rare and these people did nothing
wrong I want my son to enjoy Alaska
that's why we live here much of
America's black bear population live
beyond the wilderness of Alaska I think
one of the things that's gotten a lot of
attention here is that there are a lot
more black bears in the lower 48 people
say if I live near a black bear is our
black bears changing their behavior the
more people you have in an area with
black bears the more chances there's
gonna be a problem because there's just
more people is this us getting closer to
them or them getting closer to us well
it's both but certainly the black bear
populations have been sort of expanding
in the Northeast
something people just gonna have to get
used to I would argue that I mean if
people want to have wildlife if they
want to have those around then they have
to accept some risk both black bears
behind the predatory attacks were found
and put down the trail at Bird Ridge has
since been reopened though people are
being encouraged to carry bear spray
which there has been a run on here
recently Nora
Jeff Laura there and Alaska great to see
you there it's already light at 3:45 in
the morning huh yeah barely sets yeah be
careful Jeff Glor want you to come back
at one peace black bears but a really
great report happened there in Alaska
Alaska that's right